uh we are just a few hours away from a
very dark a very corrosive chapter in
American history with a sloppy D.A
clearly buckling to radical left-wing
political pressure is now about to cause
serious harm to our great Republic
tomorrow at 11 A.M former president
Donald Trump is expected to arrive at
New York City's Criminal Court to be
arraigned on a series of bizarre
far-fetched charges surrounding what was
a legal non-disclosure agreement signed
more than six years ago but according to
the media mob well we're watching the
crime of the century today it was O.J
Simpson and the white Ford Bronco all
over again it was John Gotti finally
being brought to Justice no man is above
the law they're cheerfully exclaimed in
unison now of course in less than 24
hours Donald Trump will be the first
former president in history to be
charged with a crime but for what
allegations of a mislabeled document
between two private citizens a hundred
and thirty thousand dollar
non-disclosure agreement phony
accusations of what a victimless
infraction a case that relies uh almost
in total of the testimony from a
convicted admitted liar a felon by the
name of Michael Cohn a case that has
never been tried before using a new
legal theory that was never applied to
anyone else and a case that looks to be
well past the statute of limitations now
the charges are so pathetically weak
that the doj the FEC Bob Mueller the
prior Manhattan district attorney all
declined to bring a case and former
Congressman by the way who voted to
impeach Donald Trump this is what he
tweeted we're going to indict a former
president for essentially misdemeanor
falsification of business records we are
Crossing the Rubicon for that that seems
like uh effing weak sauce anyway make no
mistake what we're witnessing now now
this is nothing but a blatant Act of
political persecution unfolding right
before your eyes from a repulsive
left-wing hack who had promised to take
down Donald Trump on the campaign Trail
now as the former assistant U.S attorney
for the southern district of New York
Andy McCarthy pointed out Bragg would
have not brought these charges against
any defendant not named Donald Trump
after all Bragg barely brings charges
against actual criminals violent
offenders rapists robbers more than half
get off without any felony conviction
they get a free pass an opportunity to
terrorize more innocent New Yorkers
crime keeps rising out of control in
recent days there was a gas station
stabbing in Manhattan a journalist
jumped on the subway a woman stabbed on
the sidewalk and an off-duty police
officer beaten by a biker these are all
random high-profile attacks by the way
which happen every day likely carried
out by career criminals who will
probably never see the inside of a
prison thanks to the policies of Alvin
Bragg who is too busy now going after
Donald Trump but again Bragg's watching
under under his watch in this Witch Hunt
against Trump is not about keeping
people in New York safe or secure it's
about keeping a campaign promise and
appeasing his extreme left-wing base and
persecuting political opposition Donald
Trump and criminalizing political
differences all while attempting to hurt
Donald Trump's reputation and derail his
2024 election campaign and now the U.S
has entered a new age of political
retribution so if you're Hunter Biden oh
let's see there's evidence on your
laptop of you smoking crack or hiring
prostitutes or laundry money or maybe
skirting on taxes or lying on a gun
application in a Republican state does
that mean now you can thank Alvin Bragg
if you get charged with a crime if your
name is Jim Biden Jill Biden or anyone
else from the Biden fam family or the
Clinton family well you can thank Alvin
Bragg if you now end up arrested on a
quote trumped-up charge and when Joe
leaves office or should I say the big
guy he's likely going to want to hire
some good lawyers himself because this
new era of political Justice if you want
to call it that will not begin and end
at the criminal court in Manhattan as
tomm fitton of Judicial Watch stated
quote you can be sure that there are
prosecutors all across Florida and Texas
right now looking for a state law hook
into the Biden family and if they're not
they're not doing their jobs what we
should have equal justice right equal
application of our laws the former Chief
counsel for judicial nominations Mike
Davis he told the post quote if New York
can turn a routine settlement of a
business dispute seven years ago into a
felony I think Republican AGS and DA's
should get creative so I hope this is
you know all worth it to Alvin Bragg and
all the cheerleaders in the Democratic
party and the cheerleaders in the media
mob the far left New Yorkers who elected
him on a promise to go after Trump that
was a specific promise and I hope he
enjoys his 15 minutes of fame and his
celebrity status with the media mob
because Bragg's idiotic small-minded
prosecution this will likely all
backfire in fact it already is
backfiring Donald Trump raised a
whopping 7.5 million dollars apparently
we got an update tonight since news of
the indictment broke with over a million
coming from first-time donors also a
report today that since the indictment
close to 20 000 people have signed on to
volunteer and help president Trump and
his 2024 campaign and that's not all
look at these brand new polls look at
Trafalgar that's Robert kahali's group
Trump has gained 12 points gone up 20
percent in the Republican primary and is
now well over 50 percent a poll from
Yahoo and yougov has them at 57 percent
Matt towery's Insider advantage also has
Trump at 57 percent 80 percent now
believing that the government has been
weaponized now Trump is now running neck
and neck with Biden in a general
election and beating outright Kamala
Harris handily in a head-to-head matchup
Bragg's Insidious attempt to get Donald
Trump might well catapult him right back
to the White House and hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else